Dr Zak here in the case of a person who
wishes to give zakat to a non-dependent
family member what is the ruling on this
as far as giving zakat to a family
member not dependent it is permissible
there's a Hadith mentioned inkari Vol
number two in the book of zakat Hadith
number 1462 once the prophet mham s
wasallam he was given after the Eid
whether F or
and he told to the people that give arms
give charity give zakat then he went to
the woman and told them give arms give
charity and he comes back home and then
a lady by the name of Zab May pleas with
her she comes to the house of the
prophet and says may I come in who are
you so she says I'm Zab who Zab then Zab
the wife of mas may Allah pleas with him
Prophet said yes we can come in so she
says that because you told me to give
zakat I want to give my zakat and give
the gold
jewelry but my husband Mas pleas with
him he says that no one is more
deserving than your husband and your son
so the prophet replies he's right the
most deserving of your zakat is your
husband and your son and giving to them
the best people so this proves that you
can give zakat
to your family member who's not a
dependent and further it's mentioned in
the Hadith ofi Hadith number 2583 that
giving charity to the poor is only
charity but giving charity to your near
ones it is also building
relationships so a man cannot give zakat
to his wife because she is a dependent
but a wife can give zakat to the husband
similarly a son cannot give zakat to the
mother but a mother can give zakat to a
son because a son is not dependent on
the mother it is a father whose
responsibility is take care of the
family similarly a sister can give zakat
to the brother but natural all of these
relatives or non-dependent should fall
in one of the eight categories then they
can give zakat to the relatives or non-
dependent